veamos si podemos sumar cinco y dos
quintos más tres y cuatro quintos pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolver esto
por su cuenta vamos a resolverlo juntos
ya tenemos cierta práctica sumando
números mixtos por lo que una forma de
pensar en esto es ver a cinco y dos
quintos como cinco más dos quintos y a
esto le vamos a sumar tres y cuatro
quintos que también podemos ver como
tres más cuatro quintos ahora podemos
cambiar el orden de las cosas que
estamos sumando y bueno podemos sumar 5
3 lo escribimos 5 más 3 y a esto le
sumamos dos quintos más cuatro quintos a
que es igual esto pues 53 es igual a 88
más a dos quintos y le agrego cuatro
quintos por lo que ahora hay seis
quintos 2 de algo más 4 de ese mismo
algo va a ser 6 de ese algo y el algo en
este caso son quintos por lo que ahora
hay 6 quintos y quizá algunos de ustedes
se vean tentados a decir que esto es
igual a 8 y 6 quintos y no estarían del
todo equivocado si lo dijera pero pausa
en el vídeo y traten de pensar porque
esta respuesta no es del todo correcta
la razón por la que esta no es una
respuesta estándar es porque la parte
fraccionaria de este número mixto seis
quintos es mayor a 1 por lo que hay un
entero dentro de 6 quintos la forma
estándar de hacerlo es ver si podemos
descomponer o sacar ese entero a qué me
refiero con esto podemos reacomodar 86
quintos como 8 + 6 quintos lo podemos
expresar como un entero o cinco quintos
más un quinto de qué nos sirve esto pues
cinco quintos es lo mismo que un entero
ahora podemos decir que ocho más un
entero es igual a nueve es el 8 más los
cinco quintos y lo que queda es este
quinto por lo que quedan nueve y un
quinto esta es la respuesta a la que
tradicionalmente se llega
hay otra forma en la que podemos hacer
esto aunque realmente es la misma idea
solamente escribimos las cosas un poco
diferente podemos escribir esto como
cinco y dos quintos más tres y cuatro
quintos noten como escribí esto las
fracciones están en la columna de las
fracciones por llamarle de alguna manera
y los enteros están uno abajo de otro y
si tuvieran más dígitos los alinearía
así según su valor posicional y ahora lo
que podemos hacer es sumar dos quintos
más cuatro quintos que es igual a seis
quintos podemos escribir seis quintos
aquí pero nos puede parecer extraña esta
fracción de seis quintos ya que esto en
realidad es cinco quintos más un quinto
o podemos decir que es lo mismo que un
entero más un quinto ya que seis quintos
es igual a uno y un quinto lo que
podemos hacer es escribir la parte de la
fracción aquí en la columna de las
fracciones un quinto y el entero lo
vamos a reagrupar lo ponemos en la
columna de los números
noten que dos quintos más cuatro quintos
es uno y un quinto que es lo mismo que
seis quintos y ahora sumamos la parte de
los números enteros 153 es igual a 9 por
lo que quedan nueve y un quinto espero
que se den cuenta de que ambas
representan la misma idea solo con una
forma diferente de escribirla